that thing bullying the meter movement
against masculinity is this the best a
man can get
is it we can't hide kids there's Sunny D
we can't hide it's been going on far too
long
[Music]
cuz dude let's go infer those like
really progressive [ __ ] so god forbid
they call out black people for hip-hop
so they put a white rapper there just to
make the optics look as good as possible
making the same old excuses masculinity
you woody own the world
how do you own disorder but something
final chance boy all these [ __ ] all
they got on the [ __ ] barbecue is corn
cuz there's at his corneas [ __ ] come on
to say the right thing
to act the right way give that already
there me that's Sunny D is delicious
where are these kids bullying this can
the financial district like what the
[ __ ] is going on and there will be no
going back
because we we believe in the best in men
need to hold other men accountable as a
minority is already hard enough to be an
individual because of the fact that I'm
black I have to constantly think about
the fact that I'm part of a racial group
in order to navigate the world now as a
man I also have to do that where I'm
constantly worrying about how a woman
feels in an open space because I know
that she feels unsafe around men at
night and [ __ ] so now I have to adjust
everything why do I have to carry the
burdens of an entire gender just what I
know I'm not guilty of that kind of
behavior right because people say well
this video is only being addressed to
the man who are bad but that's not what
this video says it says men have to hold
other men accountable that we have to
have play a part even if we're decent
beings so this is not just directed at
men who have bad behavior even the good
man have to be responsible somehow for
other men's behavior and I'm so sorry to
say this this ad is making it sound like
you know we don't already know that
bullying is bad that we don't already
know that harassing and sexual assault
is bad we know all these things these
are things that we know and I just just
like the idea that it's our
responsibility as a good human beings
yeah sure we should try to help each
other out as much as possible but to
make it sound like it's because I'm a
man that I have to do this that's
ridiculous that's nonsensical and men to
this day have been predominant of people
who interject and try to save other
people from the difference in situations
right it's why we're most of the police
officers it's why we're most of the
military service members it's why we're
most of the firefighters it's why we do
all the jobs that involve our physical
safety being at risk men are or very
very brave they're already putting
themselves in situations where they're
trying to save other people so to make
it sound like good men aren't already
out there trying to do that as much as
possible it's ridiculous now I don't
take credit for all men right and this
because why cuz those are individuals do
it last year we won the right and we won
their baby championship and we're on the
[ __ ] your open we know in the world
I've been waiting for my ring though
what the [ __ ] is a day I don't take
credit for all those things the same way
I don't also take credit for all their
bad [ __ ] we are individuals first and I
think that's the way we need to see
people if your masculinity can't take
Watts of commercial about treating women
better with
you demanding a boycott maybe it's cuz
you're a ginormous scumbag or maybe I
just don't like companies that are
engaging in child labor right and who
engaged in pink taxes okay trying to
virtue signal to me about how to be a
better person
on one hand you're gonna tell me how
progressive you are but I'm trying to
make men better on the other you charge
men less for the exact same product that
you charge women's more fun that's what
I walk out of my face there you go I
don't need to be preached to about how
to behave as a man from a company that
doesn't even actually practice what they
preach I'm still not mad about this [ __ ]
but all the women that are like if
you're mad about this [ __ ] well you're a
piece of [ __ ] let me go buy some razors
twice the [ __ ] price you're not
better open your [ __ ] eyes and
sometimes the people that are people the
people that are saying no this is some
[ __ ] or probably actually on your
[ __ ] five not everyone who disagrees
with you is inherently a misogynist not
everyone who disagrees with the idea of
yours is inherently against you we can
disagree and still be on the same side
of the table your teammates can disagree
with you I don't know why everything is
so confrontational I thought this
commercial was corny I get in boxes all
you're a misogynist you understand toxic
masculinity
Malana blah blah listen ladies I don't
like commercials I tried to find to me
what it means to be a man and how to be
a man okay especially what it's directed
by a woman who I can tell it doesn't
understand manhood very well which is
now listen Tommy Lauren came out a video
trying to tell us how to be real men is
it just me or men gotten really soft
these days and this has nothing to do
with sexuality by the way more so it has
to do with the helplessness of today's
young men it seems if you can change a
light bulb what alone fix a flat tire or
change oil and that makes for pretty
slim pickins for the females out there
looking for a match right and I didn't
like it and I said stay in your [ __ ]
lane you we don't need to hear from
women how we should be men and now we're
having women on the other side of the
aisle telling us once again how to be
man how to define our masculinity and
women you guys have hated the fact that
commercials for so long have told you
how to be beautiful you ought to be
good-looking how to be a human being and
it was wrong and I agree with you and
now on the flip side we're getting these
commercials directed by women telling us
how to be men and we don't relate to
those issues and we don't do relate to
these ideas and we're like why is my
razor company annoying the [ __ ] out of
me with this [ __ ] and now you guys
are looking at it's like that's how you
should be a man that is a conversation
that US men have to have amongst each
other in relation to how we treat you
now of course this affects you but it
doesn't mean that you get to define for
us how this works out the same way you
guys want to change the way you're
perceived you want to change the way
femininities perceive and man shouldn't
be part of that conversation so let's be
consistent it is not because you think
you're right that you get to define our
manhood for us you understand yeah keep
the same energy and it's not even us
being mad
we're just exposing a point Alexis next
we're gonna have a Colgate commercial
coming out saying a rape is wrong by the
way whiten your teeth wait
Colgate like rape is wrong by the way
white power the teeth of course boys
will be boys
[Music]